okay if you're watching this video
you're in my biology class and we're
gonna be performing the liver enzyme
catalase lab activity you know I want to
continue to search for ways to make our
53 minutes every day more meaningful so
instead of doing this pre lab discussion
in class I want you to watch the video
and so we can hopefully use our class
time more efficiently so I want to try
it and see how this goes so by the end
of the video you should be able to
answer the following questions what are
enzymes what is the function of the
enzyme catalase where can we find
catalase what is the formula of hydrogen
peroxide when broken down by catalase
what does hydrogen peroxide become why
aren't your cells poison to death even
though they create toxins and how can
you visually tell if hydrogen peroxide
is being broken down by catalase you
should have your lab handout with you
side-by-side as you continue this video
so pause the video go find your lab
handout and then unpause because we're
gonna continue in three two one okay so
the purpose of this lab and this lab
will hope to demonstrate the actions of
an enzyme called catalase and how
enzymes can be affected by their
environment you know pretend here's a
molecule this chain of hexagons but then
this is a molecule here's an enzyme
called catalase I've chosen animated
scissors to represent the actions of
catalase because what catalase can do is
take a big molecule and break it down
well let's go into more detail okay so
now I'm reading along from your lab
handout so look on your lab handout and
follow along with me what would happen
to your cells if they made a poisonous
chemical you might think they would die
in fact your cells were always making
poisonous chemicals they do not die
because your cells use enzymes to break
down these poisonous chemicals into
harmless substances enzymes are proteins
that speed up the rate of reactions that
would otherwise happen more slowly the
enzyme is not altered by the reaction
you have hundreds of different enzymes
in each of your cells
you know here's that same animation with
the hexagons but let me label pretend
that this big chain of hexagons was some
toxic harmful molecule catalase an
enzyme called catalase again illustrated
by my animated scissors can actually
take a harmful molecule and break it
down into two smaller harmless molecules
so far caddel a seems pretty wonderful
well let's go into more detail okay
again according to your lab handout so
follow along with me please each of
these enzymes is responsible for one
particular reaction that occurs in the
cell in this lab you will study an
enzyme that is found in the cells of
many living tissues the name of the
enzyme is catalase it speeds up a
reaction which breaks down hydrogen
peroxide h2o2 a toxic chemical into two
harmless substances one water and two
oxygen if the cells did not break down
the hydrogen peroxide they would be
poisoned and died in this lab you will
study the catalase found in liver cells
you'll be using either chicken or beef
liver in fact we're gonna use beef liver
I've tried it with chicken liver and I
don't always get the best results so
we're gonna use beef liver it might seem
strange to use dead cells to study the
function of enzymes well this is
possible because when a cell dies the
the enzymes remain intact and active for
several weeks as long as the tissue is
kept refrigerated so the chemical
reaction we're going to follow looks
like this two molecules of h2o 2
hydrogen peroxide which is a toxic
molecule will yield in the presence of
catalase 2 molecules of water and oxygen
so when we look at this animation here
here's 2 molecules of h2o 2 here's 2
molecules of hydrogen peroxide as the
lab handout says hydrogen peroxide is
toxic and this can actually build up in
our cells and actually poison ourselves
if we don't have a way of of getting rid
of it good thing we have this enzyme
called catalase catalase will take
poison
this hydrogen peroxide and break it down
into harmless molecules of water and
oxygen so catalase is wonderful at
taking this toxic peroxide and
converting it breaking down changing it
into two molecules of water and oxygen
so where do we get catalase and hydrogen
peroxide from in order to work with it
in this lab activity
well liver liver that you can buy at the
store at the grocery store is high in
catalase and I'm just gonna go down to
our grocery store buy a pound of liver
cut it up into tiny pieces that can fit
into test tubes and each piece will
contain a lot of this enzyme called
catalase and hydrogen peroxide well you
can buy that it you know CVS or rite-aid
or Walgreens or any store like that so
that's where we're gonna get the
catalase and the peroxide from well how
will we know if the catalase and the
liver is actually neutralizing the
hydrogen peroxide well let's remember
this equation two molecules of hydrogen
peroxide in the presence of catalase
will yield water and oxygen well what is
the peroxide converted into when it
comes into contact with the enzyme
catalase well like the equation says
it's converted into water and oxygen but
you know we can't really see visually
hydrogen peroxide turning into water
hydrogen peroxide is Cle as a clear
liquid water is a clear liquid but what
we can see are the oxygen forming
because bubbles should be released so we
in our test tube over here when we add
some peroxide which is toxic to the test
tube and we add a piece of the cut up
liver when the liver with the catalase
in it it comes into contact with the
peroxide we should see air bubbles begin
to form
that's our visual that we know this
chemical reaction is occurring will see
air bubbles forming which is the oxygen
gas
well what are we actually testing in
this lab activity well in my animation
we're gonna put a normal piece of cut-up
liver and a test tube and then a piece
of liver that was stored in a really
cold environment and so we're gonna test
what effect does temperature have on
this chemical reaction you know the
normal liver might produce this amount
of bubbles right here if the liver
stored in the cold temperature produces
notice the same amount of bubbles well
then we know the cold temperature it has
no impact on this chemical reaction if
our normal liver produces this amount of
bubbles and the liver stored in cold
temperature produces a much smaller
amount well then we know that the cold
temperature has a big impact on the
effectiveness of catalase and the
overall chemical reaction if our liver
is stored in the normal temperature
produces this many bubbles and the liver
stored in a real cold temperature
produces a lot more bubbles well then we
know cold temperature encourages and
speeds up the enzyme catalase and the
chemical reaction so we're going to
learn what effect temperature has not
just cold temperature but also warm
temperature well besides temperature
we're also going to study what effect
does the pH of the environment have on
the enzyme catalase and its ability to
perform this chemical reaction because
we're going to take a piece of acid a
liver that was stored in an acid
environment and a liver that was stored
in a basic air and alkaline environment
and we're going to see if the chemical
reaction is altered at all so we're
going to see what effect temperature and
pH have on the activity of this
particular enzyme called catalase okay
so there you have it I hope you're
looking forward to this lab activity you
know pause the video you should be able
to answer these seven questions here and
if not maybe watch the video over again
discuss it with a classmate with a
friend
and see me for help before school or
after school if you need to also go
ahead and pause the video and I'll see
you in class thanks for watching